hello and welcome to simply learn my
name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
going to cover the basic array in python
and some of the functionality around it
and before we jump in i'd like to please
remind you that you can always post
something in the notes here on the
youtube videos or you can go to
www.simplylearn.com and go under our
forums and ask questions there we have a
team that monitors these and they'll be
happy to answer those questions array in
python array is a container that holds
multiple values of the same type and
this is very key is that the array has
to be of the same type
so the syntax for developing your basic
array is going to be your variable
whatever you want to call it my array or
whatever you're working on equals array
your type code and then the elements in
the array this is the main types that
they have for arrays and you'll see a
quick list here character is basically
your character as you know it you have a
b c d e f g they're represented by a
number between one there's like up to
128 characters that's how many numbers
are in there so when you have assigned a
character that means that they're now
using that instead of as a character
notation it's being used as just an
actual value plus or minus unsigned
character you don't usually use a lot of
these as far as signed and unsigned
characters but it does come up for using
them for containing a small amount of
space to do something and then you have
your pi unicode the pi unicode is your
unicode characters so if you remember if
you're in the american set of characters
they use only half the memory but they
don't have all the different characters
used in different languages that's why a
lot of times you'll see especially when
you go international you need to be very
aware of whether unicode or just a
regular character and then there's an
interregular integer where they have
signed short so it has a smaller amount
of values unsigned short your signed
integer plus or minus again you're
unsigned then you have your long your
signed long unsigned long so if you want
to have a long basically is double that
so each one of these just doubles in
size and how much numbers they can hold
until you get all the way to float and
double so again those are just different
numbers and just depends on how many
significant digits you want to keep on
there that's a brief on type code
definitely we're not going to go into
too much detail any more detail on that
but we do want to jump in and actually
do an array and start showing you how
the arrays work and what you can do with
them now to do this you're going to use
your favorite python editor or ide your
interface i myself go through anaconda
and jupiter notebook certainly if you're
using any other interface i'll work just
the same this is very basic code in
python i use anaconda because it's a
great navigator for following your
different modules you install into your
python and it has different packages and
then jupyter notebook sits on there
there's also spyder which is another
python editor there's a ton of python
editors out there but we'll go ahead and
launch our jupiter notebook
once i'm in the jupyter notebook it
opens up whatever folder it's set to and
i can simply go under new and i'm going
to create a new python 3
and that will open up my python3
notebook so now i can start writing code
and we'll start off the bat by importing
so we're going to from array import
we're going to import all the different
functionality that the array offers and
then we're going to create our first
array we'll just call it arr or we can
call my array or whatever you'd like and
it is simply array and then we're going
to put in the type and then we'll go
ahead and just put in brackets what we
want for an array
and we'll do one comma two comma three
comma four comma five real simple array
and then let's go ahead and just print
that out and see what that looks like
and we get an array of type integer one
two three four five and then let's flip
over and just remember what the i is
lowercase is signed integer and
uppercase is assigned this is a
lowercase we have a signed integer this
um it's actually a short integer when
you do the i and then the h is the
unsigned short integer and to see what
that means when we're assigning this
let's go up here and change one of our
values to minus one and we have it set
to i and we run it and it comes out okay
no errors but what happens when we
change this to h which is the unsigned
short inner integer we run this we're
going to get an error why because we
gave it a minus value and if you
remember correctly from the h
h is an unsigned short integer so there
should be no negative values in there
and we'll go ahead and go back and just
switch this to i and run it
and then there's so many things we can
do with this but let's start by looking
at what's going on in the computer array
buffer underscore info there we go and
when you do an array buffer info we're
just going to print this out and we run
this this is going to show us the size
of what's going on with our buffer in
here this is our actual operating system
address and then the size is here it's
got a size of five so you can actually
go in there and you could hard locate
this on your computer usually we very
rarely use something like that but it's
kind of interesting that we can look
that up so easily and when we're
manipulating the array we can simply do
print here's our array we'll put our
brackets in here and if we print two let
me go ahead and run this and you look at
this we got minus one two three and it
printed three and the reason it does
that is we always count from zero so in
programming language you always start 0
1 2 and the 2 is going to be the section
where it says 3 on there and if we can
print just one object in there this next
one is so basic
the for statement for i an array this is
a simple iteration so what this means is
we're going to take each value in the
array we're going to do something with
it and in this case we're going to go
ahead and just print it out so if we
want to print out all the variables you
could go for i and array print i
i once you notice the difference here is
instead of it printing out that this is
an array with the values in it it comes
down and just prints each individual
value in here now this does all of them
but let's say you are looking at this
you say hey i don't want to do all of
them we're going to do for we'll do
pointer instead of i for pointer in
range
and instead we're going to print
and here's our array r
and we're going to look up the index
pointer so this is going to print out
let's just see what this looks like here
we go it printed out the same thing so
we have our minus 1 2 3 4 5.
so it starts at 0 1 2 3 4 5 on here oops
0 1 2 3 4 on here that's how this is
actually red on here so if you actually
print out the pointer let's do that
let's just print out the pointer on here
so you can see what's going on
pointer comma
r pointer and let's run that
and you can see that the pointer zero
one two three four so it does not
include the five and it prints at each
value we can do something like this we
can go four and you can see it just
drops the bottom one off and we can even
do something like this range one to four
and it drops the top one off so by
changing your iteration loop you can
change the pointer and pull up any of
these values in your array and another
really cool thing we can do we have our
array we can actually do array
reverse so instead of iterating and
creating a new array we now have
functionality in our array just lets us
reverse all the different values and
then if we go ahead and print the array
let me go and run that you'll see that
the array is now in reverse
minus one 5432-1 let's just do a quick
rehash of what we covered so we went
over here and we're gonna go on more
there's three sections to this or two
another section or two we imported our
array so make sure you always import it
we set our value so we created array
equals array we have a type and then we
have the values in that type and if you
print it out you can see that it's an
array type i minus one two three four
and five we can look up the buffer info
so we can actually pull out the actual
memory location and then what kind of
resources it's using that's what the
five represents and then we came in here
we printed just one value out of it and
we remember that it goes starts with
zero so we have zero one two which
prints our three position there our
number three we learn how to iterate
through the whole array for i and arr or
i in our array and we just printed the i
out and then we did for pointer in range
one to four we started off with range
five and you can see here where it goes
one two three and it printed out the
values that correspond with that pointer
and finally we went ahead and reversed
the array so we have our r dot reverse
print r
and then the next step with our array is
we want to go ahead and add something
onto it we do that simply with an append
so here's our append we're going to
append the value 10 and let's go ahead
and print array and now we have 5432
minus 1 10. so we've entered that right
on to the end of the array and we can
also if we're going to pin something we
can also remove something so the simple
command is remove and we're going to
remove two and then let's go ahead and
print that
print
r
run and you'll see here the value 2 is
now missing from the array so it goes
through and it finds number two in here
and this leads into an interesting
question what happens if we have two
values of the same or two twos there we
go we're gonna put in two twos so let's
go ahead and i'm just gonna copy this
down here and recreate our array and i'm
going to add a second 2 in here 2 comma
2. and let's see what happens when we
remove the 2 from there it removes one
of the two and the way it works is it
removes only the first two in the list
so we do the remove value on there you'd
have to rerun this a number of times to
get all the different twos out
now earlier we did print
here's our r and we can do position
let's do position three we'll just run
that
and position three happens to point to
four
what if we wanted to do something in
reverse like print
r dot
index
and i'm gonna put the four in there and
let's see what happens it prints three
which was our pointer so index does the
reverse and if you remember correctly
when we did uh let me go ahead and do
let's just take this whole array and
recreate it again
and i'm going to change the index from
the three to the 2 3 is actually going
to point to one of the twos because we
have to see 0 1 2. so we're going to do
index of 2 let's run that we have 0 1 2
and i did my argument of 2 which is
going to come up as 2. but when i did my
index the index is only 1. y because 0
1. it's going to look at the first two
in the array so when you do your index
remember if there's multiple 2s in that
array it's only going to look at the
first one and then we'll go in here in
front we have our array imported and
let's go ahead and create a new array
this one we're just going to make as an
empty array it's going to be the i will
stick with that
and it has no values in it so that's
what this means and if we print it out
just print our array we say we just have
an array with no there's no values in
there nothing coming through and so we
want to go ahead and do on this array is
we're going to create an input and we'll
set a variable x equal to it has to be
an integer so it's going to restrict it
it's going to be an input
and then from our input we'll give it
what's the enter
size of array there we go enter on this
and then let's do print what did we do
let's do it this way enter d
element x this is kind of a fun thing we
can set up on here this has to do with
print format on here so let's take a
look at this real quick and see what's
going on before we do our print let me
just take the print out there and let's
run this and of course it helps if i
match my brackets correctly there we go
so we're going to enter the size of
array so this is what this is going to
generate the first one generates our
input box and let's just put a 4 in
there just to see what that looks like
and we're going to run that and so at
this point we're not getting anything
coming out make sure i get all my
brackets in the right place there and
try it again so we're going to enter the
array four i hit the enter key and it's
going to print out enter four elements
so this is a marker in your print
statements for formatting and it just
lets us know we're going to take the x
value we're going to put it in there and
then from here we're going to do 4i and
range in this case x and this should
look familiar from earlier so we're
going to do if it's in range of x and i
enter the number 4 in it's going to go 0
1 2 3. three always starts at zero on
the range and we're going to do n equals
integer input
there we go and if you look at this this
is just another input statement just
like we had integer input inner size of
array now i have integer input again
we're not going to do we can actually do
like have it print something out but
we're just going to leave that blank
i'll show you what that looks like in a
second and we're going to append that
new value to our array and then let's
print it out let's print out our array
so let's go ahead and take a look and
see what this looks like when i run it
let's create an array of four since that
seems to be fun and it says enter four
elements so element one two three four i
hit enter and we print out our array we
see that i have an array of one two
three four so i can use a user input
just like this a real simple setup but
allows me to enter the data into the
array and then finally we're going to
remove the duplicate elements from the
array and we're going to do this is
first of all create another array what
we'll do let's see we'll keep it as the
i keep it all uniform it shouldn't make
it different and if we have we already
have our setup up here you know what
let's just keep the array we already
have our array we did let's just keep
that one and let's rerun this and we'll
do five elements
and we'll do one
two two
three three and you'll see here we have
a nice array of one two two three three
on there and so we're going to create
this is kind of an interesting setup
because we're doing nested loops and so
the logic in these can sometimes get
confusing and they come up more than you
think in programming and you always got
to be careful because when we create
multiple loops
you always run into the problem adding
more resources like you're running
through everything multiple times and so
we're going to start with our while
statement and we're going to start with
um i equals 0 while i is less than x
minus 1. oops i forgot to put in my x oh
yeah we already have the x so i'm
pulling this value of x this is how many
elements are in our array okay so we're
just going to reuse that x that's where
this x comes in and we're going to do
wall i is less than x minus 1. we're
going to do j
equals i
plus one and there's a lot of ways to do
this so if you come up with another
solution kudos to you i actually have
about four or five different solutions
depending on the detail the project i'm
working on for something simple like
this any one of them will probably work
and we're going to take if our array of
i
equals remember to do two equal signs
for doing a boolean function j so let's
just take a quick look at this we want
to make sure that one j and x are not
equal that's words keep j greater than x
because that's the way it should go up
incrementally j equals i plus one j
should always be greater than x because
i is always less than x minus one and
we're going to go up here and say hey if
array i equals array j so we have two
loops going on the first one is our i
loop going up and then our j group going
up so as long as j is less than x we
keep going up on the j until we get to x
there we go we want to just delete it
delete
j just removes it right out of the
system and then we want to take x equals
x minus 1. why because our x array is
now one less this is the length of our x
array so it doesn't make sense to go
past the end you'll get an error and
then we want to go ahead and increment
let's see go back to there we go j
plus equals one so we're going to add
one to our j value and then we're going
to go back one more there we go oops i
think i went too far j there we go this
j goes here there we go and then x
is going to equal x minus 1. so our x
value is going down in one oops i had
this
that's what i did up here that's the
size of the array going down down here
is just i plus equals 1. and this is
shorthand you could do i this is the
same as i equals i plus one and you
could do i times equals one all right is
the same as i times one so your basic
math functions you can put them right in
here like this it's just a shorthand
which is really nice and we're just
incrementing our values on here so you
can see what that looks like just like
this x equals x minus 1 i can also do
this
x minus equals 1. we can also change
this to a minus 1 and do x plus minus
one and that increments it down one
those are all equal so just some quick
short hands makes life a little easier
and finally let's go ahead and print
our array and let's see what happens
here
and voila if you look at the original
array was one two two three three we now
have an array of one two three and this
is involving two different loops again
this is basic array manipulation and
basic iteration through your array there
are so many different ways to do this
this is using pointers that's important
to note so we're not just doing like for
i in array we're doing i as a pointer
and we're incrementing the pointers
manually and there's other ways to do
this i can do a for loop and then have
it go backwards from the end of the
array and just see if the last value is
in the array that's another way to do it
so there's all kinds of cool ways to do
this but this is one solution that looks
really nice
generally
be very careful whenever you nest or
raise remember you're iterating through
the data for each piece of data you're
iterating through the data so you're
multiplying your iterations so if i have
five pieces of data and none of them are
duplicated that's basically five minus
one is four but it's basically five
times four calculations i'm doing so 20.
and you can see if i had a third loop in
here that'd be five times four times
three if i was doing another iteration
see that can happen so be a little
careful with these iterations through
loops but you can see here how we went
ahead and we were able to manipulate our
iterations through the loop to delete
each of the values so let's go ahead and
let's uh go back through this real quick
and look at what we did from the
beginning we did our import we created
our array we looked at the buffer so we
know where it is in the actual computer
we looked at looking at one value in the
array we looked at going through an
iteration of all the values in the array
we looked at going through range and
printing out the pointer in the array we
reversed our array we then took and
appended a value to the array we removed
one of the values in the array if you
remember below there's a way to do the
removal of multiple values using the
same thing so wall 2 is in the array you
could do a remove too that's another way
to do it we had our array here where we
did a print index which looks at the
first index or the first pointer in the
array we came down and did an enter and
created an array using our interface and
then finally we deleted all our
duplicates out using two separate loops
to iterate through the data that wraps
up our basic commands in array i'd like
to thank you for joining us today for
more information visit
www.simplylearn.com get certified get
ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here